the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
as you can see by the title of the video
I want to talk about the new deleted
scenes from Game of Thrones I don't know
how many of you have seen these yet but
I do have to say they're very
interesting the deleted scenes I want to
show you today all have to do with the
bran stark now as we all know bran has
had many different dreams visions and
flashbacks over the years this started
happening right after Jaime had thrown
bran from the tower window it was at
this time when the three-eyed Raven
started to visit brain in his dreams
this is when brand started to open his
third eye which allows him to see
certain events from the past present and
even the future most of us have been
trying to decipher what all the
different visions actually mean some say
these visions could be possible clues to
how Game of Thrones will end
since HBO decided to delete these scenes
maybe that's because they gave away too
much information what I want to do today
is take a look at the scenes to see if
we can find any clues about how the show
could end now before we get started I do
want to give everyone a heads up some of
the scenes I will show you today could
be seen as a little creepy to say the
least
if I were you I would not watch the
video at work or around any little kids
as we all know ever since brain stark
has become the new three-eyed Raven he
has started to act a lot different than
he used to one of the biggest examples
of this was when bran and songs are
reunited last season during their
conversation out by the weirwood Sheree
brain said something to Sansa that
appeared to send chills down her spine
for some reason bran thought it was a
good idea to talk about one of the most
traumatizing moments in Songz's life in
case any of you forgot take a look at
the scene it was so beautiful that night
snow falling just like now
and you were so beautiful
and your white wedding dress
I have to go back inside Bram I'll stay
a bit longer
I really don't know why branch owes to
talk about that but it just goes to show
you what type of thoughts and images he
has floating around inside of his head I
guess we all should have seen that
coming because brain has been watching
characters have sex ever since the very
first episode of the show we all can't
forget the scene when brand caught
Cersei and Jaime having sex together
which essentially kicked off the entire
story
are you completely mad
it's alright it's alright it's alright
he saw us I heard you the first time
then of course we have the scene from
last season where we got one of our
biggest revelations brand Saul Rhaegar
and Lyanna get married at the exact same
time John and Daenerys were having sex
so it does become quite clear that bran
has some sort of connection to some of
the other characters most intimate
moments now let's take a look at the
scenes because there may be some new
clues about how Game of Thrones ends the
first scene takes place right after
brain and Meera escape from the
three-eyed Ravens cave this was when
bran was having to download basically
the entire history of Westeros as Meera
is trying to run from all the whites
brain is downloading all the different
images from some of the biggest events
over the course of the story the only
difference is HBO deleted one of the
scenes from brains vision I'm not really
sure why Bryan had to see that scene but
it might be very telling let's take a
look
[Music]
Wow okay
for some reason bran was watching Danny
and Drago have sex I guess we should not
be surprised when it comes to brain
stark now what does it actually mean
well maybe it has something to do with
Danny's vision at the house of the
undying
maybe Daenerys and called Drogo are
meant to reunite in the afterlife
or bran just wanted to watch Danny have
sex I don't know let's move on to the
next deleted scene this one might reveal
a little more information that we can
actually use this deleted scene is from
the very first season of the show I
believe this is from what a brain Starks
dreams now most of what he sees are
things that are telling him to find a
three-eyed Raven this would all
eventually lead to brand becoming the
new three-eyed Raven but HBO deleted one
scene that may be indicating something
else there has to be a good reason why
bran was originally shown this clue
let's see what it is
though for me you would be a wonderful
King what the hell was that all about
why did Brian need to see Renly and
Loras was that meant to be some of the
foreshadowing for Renly raising his
banners against the crown and his own
brother that sort of is what Loras was
talking about in that scene but what
else could it mean
maybe Loras going down on Renly was
symbolizing something maybe that means
bran will have to escape from Winterfell
than head down south but where would he
go I'm not exactly sure just yet but
let's watch some of the other deleted
scenes because maybe they all connect in
some way now the next deleted scene is
when bran Hodor Jojen and Meera are
travelling north beyond the wall this is
when bran has her door set him down in
front of the weirwood tree I believe
this is the first time we see bran touch
a tree to download visions what he sees
this time is slightly different than
what HBO originally released let's have
a look maybe this one is easier to
dissect
for me it is true what they say about
the northern girls okay I don't know
what the hell that was all about but I
am starting to notice a bit of a pattern
here bran is either the biggest creep in
Westeros or maybe that just means
they're all [__] now we did see Roz
and Tyrion in this scene maybe this one
is symbolizing something as well we saw
rose going down on Tyrion
so maybe bran really does have to go
south to beat the night king I don't
know what else this could mean now there
is one last vision and I do believe this
one gives us the biggest clue now this
one takes place when brain is training
with the three-eyed Raven this is when
bran notices the three-eyed Raven has
his eyes closed so brain takes advantage
of the opportunity that way he can go
exploring instead of the weirwood net by
himself if you remember correctly this
was when the night king reaches out and
grabs bran by the arm that was what we
ended up getting to see in the show but
HBO originally had a different scene in
mind for some reason they decided to
delete one of the other things that
Bryan saw during that scene so let's
take a look to see what brain sees
I do believe my Lords in love for many
years most of my life really play with
her ass holy [__]
now that is very interesting what the
hell could that actually mean
why did bran see Littlefinger telling
Raza to stick a finger in her ass could
that have been the foreshadowing for
bran having to reveal all of little
fingers dirty little secrets or does
that mean bran will have to leave
Winterfell to travel down to the gods
brown eye I don't know but I have a
feeling that fans will be analyzing that
vision for many years to come let me
know what you think about all of this I
need everyone to help me decipher these
new deleted scenes leave your thoughts
down below anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching today's video
I really appreciate that and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel I hope everyone
has a great April Fool's Day and I hope
to see you all come back for the next
one bye
[Music]